what the [ __ ] to test
ich will nicht warum läufst durch nicht
durch hallöchen liebe freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu captain
minecraft zusammen mit gott minecraft
freunde willkommen zurück ich weiß nicht
ich denke ich denke nicht dass seine
schiefen ist nähe ist wegen nicht aber
ich habe jetzt hier auf jeden fall mit
angepflanzt doch das wird gleich noch
ein archiv mit und wächst weil wir uns
anders können wir uns ja es stimmt ich
habe sechs eier gibt es nicht mehr das
kuchen
man kann ein kuchen machen
na klar kann man den machen ja als
archiv layer erweisen und brot guck mal
oben bei dem ich weiß ich weiß was du
meinst die macht meiner normalen kuchen
da muss ich dann brauchst alles mögliche
wirklich das weizen genau milch können
wir aber machen keine kuh
ja dies tut wiese konnte wie konnte
diese quote
diese arme arme kuh du hast du dann noch
eine kugel töten
ja wir hätten die vielleicht beide
bleiben lassen sollen und paten sollen
die eisenerz
eisenerz ja was hallo ich bin ja gerade
dabei diesen ganzen hält man sich noch
übrig habe die ich eigentlich schon
lange erledigt haben müsste die bin ich
ja gerade abarbeiten a
schade denn ich habe gerade mal überlegt
moment überlegt hat der baum wird auch
gleich wir wachsen obwohl die bauern
wollen wenn wir doch moment ich guck mal
ganz kurz nach dem start ist denkens und
uns klappt und ich hatte ganz italien
denken fehler ich habe gerade gedacht
nee das ist das ist weniger die jetzt
komm ass monsterjäger nix gebracht
glaube ich nix gebracht wo ich habe die
fakten halbherzig brauche wieder nahrung
ich brauche mein stein schwer tel
ich habe auch noch nie ja ich weiß
hast du holz für mich ja elf stimme
hey hey hey hier auf stimme.de facto
tötet tötet ich will nicht und ich bin
gleich tot
ich bin gott warum läufst dann durch
mich durch wo bin ich
aber ich bin zum glück oben an der
oberfläche gestorben
warum läufst du denn durch mich durch
nein ich nehme doch auch du hast das du
du wirst es in meiner aufnahme sehen du
meinst hörte das skelett ich schlag auf
das klett und du läufst durch das gerät
durch durch meine arbeit schützen weil
das nicht nötig und richtig zu mir
teleportieren nenne ich eine
herunterspringen glaube ich ja du bist
dieser plattform mit ganz vielen pick
zombies sind ja das ist als unsere
fehler dass man manchmal nach oben und
alles das habe ich ja schon gesagt hier
ist auch ein gast wtf aber du stirbst du
dann auch wieder das ist ja dass im
reich eines toten
perfekt so ich weiß nicht welche ganzen
sagt das hat glaube ich dir gehört das
bei mir erwartete fleischer sich
mahlzeit dankeschön das einfach einer
muss ja auch mal anfangen ihre
sicherheit sagen auch ich hatte da so
ein paar sachen hingeschmissen
er weiß nicht welches davon als 130
schön aber wie ich auch
auseinandergeflogen bitten
es war sogar noch mal eine zeitlupe wenn
du es nicht verletzt eine zeitlupe auf
video ja doch doch doch youtube will als
60 fps unterstützen das wäre ein killer
das wäre echt geil also ohne witz da
kann man viele coole gameplays noch
besser sein
kannst du mir holstein geben steinbrück
dann mach ich mir jetzt eben ein haus
zwei stücke gibt 18
weil ich hier ja ja das ist mir auch
langsam
2 soweit ich packe jetzt mal alle sachen
hier die ich erst mal nicht braucht
jetzt da oben mal größer werden so hier
kommen wachse wachse ja wohl so ich
mache mir noch ein paar fackeln für
jeden von uns
ich will braucht dann wohl jeder
ich hab mir jetzt erstmal steuerung ich
geb dir auch mal zwölf perfekt
so da sind eine 12 ganz schön viel holz
das ist ja ich hab das einzige was ich
habe in die kiste gepackt auch so aja
danke danke danke ich hab ja dass ich
wir haben auch schon sieben eier
ich schaue mal ganz kurz nach wie viel
sonnen kuchen kuchen minecraft so ich
hab mir kann man etwas richtig schönes
gegönnt kuchen ist wahrscheinlich nur
zweit gegriffen wir müssen ja ich wollte
das bei mir ja nehmen und das mal bei
mir barocke das kann alles ein bisschen
soeben hatte ich den fluch des rückens
jetzt eventuell durch hoffentlich jetzt
geht wie ich mach mal ganz kurz das
wächst jetzt habe ich nämlich schon ein
weizen
wir haben ja in monster's ball ja immer
dass das rot aber echt eklig ja bei mir
auch wir haben quasi genug monster die
spawn ja einfach so hier unten in der
höhle ja alter da liegt gold nugget
außerhalb und das ist aber nicht von uns
oder oder dass du die goldmarie im
inventar in ja eigentlich nicht denn was
wollte ich noch mal gerade sagen total
also die die monsters bauen ja die ganze
zeit das ist ja nicht so tieres bauen ja
irgendwie nur noch werden halt einfach
so also die sbornaja nicht nur wenn du
eine fackel setzt kommen nicht ihre das
war ganz ganz damals beim eine
genauigkeit frage dieses weizen wächst
einfach teilweise nicht das liegt
einfach wieder weg wie ihr bei der über
läufst du davon habe ich doch mal auf du
darfst tatsächlich kaputt trampeln also
ach so ich dachte das kameragehäuse
übergeben wird
ja es ist trotzdem kaputt gegangen ich
hab's dahingestellt
vielleicht wegen der hühnchen weil die
münchner oder sport er und oder wegen
münchen genau sie dürfen noch nicht nur
laufen
ich hab jetzt die hühnchen mal gepaart
wir haben neue hühnchen wir haben
kollegen führen für nahrung
übrigens durch mein team gerade auch
nahrung gespart denn ich hatte schon
gehört
ja ich bin und in höhlen ich habe gold
gefunden warum warum warum warum warum
warum warum warum es weiter
erfolg er heimkommt gemacht 8 okay wir
haben neue coop die laster weimar leben
wollen wir dass ich habe übrigens hier
unten gold gefunden
wir müssen die kuh leben lassen sich
damit wie die kurt wernli kann und dann
für auch für essen nachher oder ist ein
ende
ich habe jetzt einfach mal an gibt es so
gut wie der neue höhle gefundenen
kontrakte haben eine menge tötet oder
besser nicht treiben lassen möchtest du
runter kommen und die höhle mit mehr
forschen hier erst mal mein brot ja ich
komme zu dir dies gefährlich also ich
weiss nicht leitern wegen ganz geil aber
leider muss man so runter springt kann
uns eben leichter machen ein paar und
baum ist gewachsen obwohl leiter
prävention nicht viel obwohl doch ein
bisschen aber nie kommen einfach runter
am besten kreisen ich bringe jetzt
leiter mit und nahrung nahrung braucht
ob ich guck mal ich komm hoch und holen
nochmals nahrung und ganzen immer fest
wie viele leute brauchen wieder ein ca
12 reichen locker gut nahrung habe ich
nicht so viel aber wir haben ja keine
nahrung
red bull also wer münchen aber keine
nahrung zu mir du das doch mal bitte mit
dem mit den samen ob du die dahin setzen
kannst mache ich ja wo liegen sie hat
die dir da leben geschlossen
ok pass auf was soll mit gefühl machen
ok damit stehen sagt er verstehe ich
nicht das habe ich nicht verstanden das
ist nur bei den beiden blöcken das ist
auch nicht wegen dem ruder weil das
umstritten nicht drauf ich habe keine
ahnung wann das liegt etwas will die
ecke erstmal aus oder hat würde ich auch
sagen wir haben auch folgt bbva so schön
fähig so obwohl wir müssen uns auch
vielleicht mal irgendwann dann ein haus
bauen dass wir vielleicht auch noch ganz
cool
die neue haus hätten und so weiter
vielleicht wäre es auch mal wenn wir
ganz viele spinnen töten können jetzt
wolle machen oder vielleicht auch noch
mal irgendwo auf dem bogen bogen machen
ja doch irgendwie auf dem bett hätten
damit wir nicht mehr da oben so eklig
spawnen wegen diesem pack oder so ja was
machen wir es wegen dem nahrungs problem
also ich alles nicht wie gehören
einerseits natürlich warten bis das hier
wächst ich setze mir fackeln in einfach
ich glaube das geht dann schneller wenn
du bist du was neben ist kann man
eigentlich auch ausdruck in den fischen
die bekommt man sich hieraus glaube ich
liebe kommt man aus einem größeren
speicher vorne oder hinten da können wir
auch angeln stimmt gut
wir könnten ja auch eigentlich schon mal
nach oben laufen wenn wir irgendwann
gleich sagen ok kommen
das nehme ich habe da auch noch ein
bisschen ja dann kann man sehr hoch
bauen da schon wieder ändern
oh ja drauf da ich habe ein schwert das
eisen schwert ja genau einen links gibt
jedoch eine perle jährlich sie lege ich
meine die truhe vielleicht mal braucht
man die noch mal kennen ich mache mir
auch mal locker so was ich mache jetzt
auch mal eisenstäben
nun macht das so dann komme ich mal mit
nach unten zu dir aber schon wieder ganz
viel eisen cool jazz schmiede konzert in
berlin hatte ich doch schon oder er
genau die wird auch nicht größer ist
schade
damit komme contractor bei dir ist ein
grüner pfeil von schmiede von reisen zum
bahn frei oder von anträgen mit einer
lore mindestens einen kilometer an einem
stück zurück es ist ein ein kilometer
jeweils nicht nicht dann müssen wir uns
vielleicht einfach so ein rundkurs bauen
und einer schubst ein die ganze zeit an
können wir das machen wohl können wir
machen ich baue ebenen lore du hast ja
ich hab die schienen gesetzt eine sehr
gute idee
das hatte ich nämlich mal gerade
überlegt da steht nämlich vorher
nachgedacht als dann da damit noch
gedacht dass es keinen sinn ergibt
du hast dich ihn rausgenommen ja so ich
hatte zwei größeren rundkurs gemacht
erst recht so spaßig aus radio ich nicht
was du hast alles macht ihr mal so dann
macht komische oder mehrere video ich
schon kanada nicht immer so ein bisschen
jahren auf dieser strecke das deine
beschleunigungs ob andere richtung oder
etwas ganz schöner zwischenzeit schon
mal machen ich weiß ja auch jetzt nicht
also ich kann mal eben gucken bei
erfolge wir sagen immer denn nicht
aufgesetzt und maike hat obwohl nein das
muss ja du jetzt machen und stimmt das
ist nicht in die weitergabe der welt
natürlich aber hier auf speed das geht
aber ab hier kannst du dich alleine so
anstupsen oder mache ich das immer ich
kann das alleine ein wenig und das ging
es mir ist lag die so ein wenig gas
seien ja das liegt aber glaube ich
einfach am neuen snapshot das dennoch
nicht so stable ist ja aber du bist
schon schnell unterwegs
da muss man sagen ich hab's wald ich
habe es hoffentlich bald kommt schon
noch ein bisschen der rundkurs 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 oder kein reagiert dass sich war
hier wird weißt du du musstest
hundertmal rumfahren
ich fahre hier gott ok ich würde sagen
da ziehen wir dann in der nächsten folge
zumal da drin sitzt du ich muss mir
enden wir sind wir wieder voll über die
zeit
du kannst mir dabei zugucken wie ich
neben dir sitzen und ich an feuer und
alles was ein zeitraffer so ganz schnell
weiße oder soja wir schauen wir werden
das schon ewig in kriegen aktuell ist
man da drin sitzt war noch ein bisschen
salz durch kadir wenn es euch gefallen
hat und ihr euch das ganze projekt
gefällt und vor allem das sieht ja schon
richtig cool aus unsere kleine hat wir
haben das ist schon in ordnung ist auf
jeden fall wir erhalten immer mehr
rohstoffe und bauen uns immer weiter aus
ist schon ne hammer
also kommt man schon wir werden uns dann
diamanten müssen vielleicht noch finden
aber hier wird auf jeden fall diamanten
geben auf jeden fall weil sonst kann man
hier erfolgreich machen fische können
wir uns gleich noch machen alles
mögliche sehr viele sachen gold finden
für ein apfel und dann noch brot habe
ich ja schon gemacht aber damit man so
einen kuchen machen
der glaube fehlt noch ein bisschen
weiter in seinem kleinen mine card teil
und das müssen wir schnell
ich würde auf jeden fall so angesetzt in
der nächsten folge wieder morgen bei
gomez muss mich an chips sind schirme